The owner of a restaurant
wants to find out more about
where his patrons
are coming from.
One day, he decided
to gather data
about the distance
in miles that people
commuted to get
to his restaurant.
People reported the
following distances traveled.
So this is our data
right over here.
He wants to create a graph
that helps them understand
the spread of the distances
and the median distance
that people travel.
What kind of a graph
should he create?
And you can plot this data in
many different types of graphs,
but they tend to depict
things in different ways.
For example, a line graph
shows a trend over time.
He's not interested
in a trend over time,
so a line graph
doesn't make sense.
Or a line graph could be a trend
of one variable with respect
to another variable.
It doesn't just have to be time.
But he doesn't want
to see a trend here.
A bar graph is good
when you're trying
to bucket things, put
things into buckets
and see how those
buckets are performing.
Once again, that's not
exactly what he wants to see.
A pie graph, if you
want to see kind
of how things make up a whole.
That's not what he wants
to see right over here.
A stem and leaf plot does
help with distributions
a little bit, but
it really doesn't
tackle the median distance and
the spread really, really well.
So the one that
does, and especially
when people talk about
medians and spread,
is a box and whiskers plot.
And I'll show you how
to do it right now.
Box and whiskers.
And what a box and whisker
plot literally does
is it shows the
spread of the data.
It splits it into quartiles.
And I'll talk about
that in a second.
And it also tells you where the
median of the data actually is.
And that's one of the
things that the owner
of the restaurant cares about.
So whenever you're
dealing with medians--
and box and whisker plots deal
with medians-- the first thing
you want to do is
order all the numbers
because the median is really
the middle number when
you order them all up.
So let's order this.
So let's write it in order.
So first we have 1.
So we get rid of that 1.
Then we have one
2 right over here.
And then we have another
2 right over there.
That's all of our 2's.
Then we have this 3, that
3, and then we have that 3.
So those are two people
who have to travel
3 miles to the restaurant.
Then let's see, do
we have any 4's?
We have one 4 right over there.
And then we have another
4 right over there.
Then, let's see,
do we have any 5's?
Actually, I just realized
that I skipped one of the 1's.
We have another 1
right over there.
So let's write that
1 right over there.
We actually had two 1's.
And then let's see.
Do we have any 5's?
We do not have
any 5's over here.
Do we have any 6's?
We have one 6 right over here.
And then we have no more 6's.
Do we have any 7's?
We have one 7 right over there.
8's.
We have an 8 right over there
and that's the only one.
Let's see.
Do we have any 9's?
No 9's.
Any 10's?
Yes, we have a 10.
Do we have an 11?
Yep.
11.
Do we have any 12's?
No 12's, no 13's.
14?
14.
And we have a 15.
People must like
this restaurant.
They're traveling a good bit.
Then we have a 20 and
then we have a 22.
So I've ordered all the numbers.
Let me make sure I
haven't skipped or gotten
some duplicates.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16,
17 people were surveyed, 17
patrons of the restaurant.
And we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17.
All right.
Seems like I've got all of
them and I've ordered them now.
Now the median is
the middle number.
We just said that we
had 17 of these numbers.
So we want the
number-- and since it's
an odd number of numbers,
the median actually
will be one of these numbers.
It's actually the middle number.
It'll be the number
where eight are larger
and eight are smaller.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So it looks like
this is our median.
It will be the ninth number.
And then you have 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8 that are larger.
So eight are smaller than
6, eight are larger than 6.
So 6 is the middle number.
If we had an even
number of numbers here,
if we had two middle
numbers, then we
would take the average of them.
When you have an odd
number of data points,
then you can just
take the middle one.
So this one right over
here is our median.
And then when you do a box
plot, what you want to do
is you want to find the
median of the set of numbers
that are smaller
than the median.
And you also want to find the
median of the set of numbers
that are larger than the median.
These are called
the first quartile
and the second quartile.
Because when you do
that, you split your data
into four sections,
or quartiles.
"Quar," you'd normally
associate with four.
So let's look at the set
that's smaller than 6.
So we have 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8 numbers.
So it's an eight.
If you have eight
data points, you're
going to actually have
two middle numbers.
So for example, you have
these two right over here
are the two middle numbers--
three less, three more.
You can't just pick the
2 because if you just
picked the 2, you'd have
three less and four more.
And you can't just pick
the 3 because then you
would have three
more and four less.
So these are our
middle two numbers.
So the median of this group
right over here is 2.5.
I averaged these
middle two numbers.
And then let's do it over
here with this group.
I'll do it in blue.
So once again, we
have eight numbers.
You're going to
have two middles.
And so it's going to be the
third and the fourth number,
which is 11 and 14.
And if you average 11
and 14-- let's see.
11 plus 14 is 25, divided
by 2 is 12.5, is 12.5.
So this essentially divides
the data into four sections.
You have everything up
to this first quartile.
So you have this first
section right over here,
this first median of the
lower half of the data is 2.5.
Then you have everything between
2.5 and 6, then 6 to 12.5,
and then everything
more than 12.5.
And so what a box
and whisker plot
is essentially a
graphical depiction
of this right over here.
So let's do that.
I'm going to set
up a number line.
So let me draw a number line
as straight as possible.
So let's say that
is my number line.
And let's say that this is 0.
And let's say that this
is-- I want to make it.
So let's say that this is 10.
And then this would be 20.
And then this would be 5.
This would be-- let me do it a
little bit cleaner than that.
This would be 15.
25 would be right around there.
So first thing on the
box and whiskers plot,
you want to show the
entire range of data.
So our smallest data
point starts at 1.
So 1 is right about here.
So if I do-- so this is 2.5.
And then our largest
data point is 22.
22 would sit right about there.
And I'll even label
it, although you often
won't see it labeled like that.
That's 1.
And then that is 22.
And then the middle half of
the data, we do with a box.
So the middle half
is this quartile
and this quartile
right over there.
So the second quartile
starts at 2.5.
So 2.5 is right there.
So this is where we
start our box, 2.5.
And then our third
quartile starts at 12.5.
So 12.5 is right over there.
12.5 is right over there.
And then we can draw a box.
I'll draw the box
in a neutral color.
I'll do it actually
in that yellow color.
So let me draw the box here.
So the box shows where the
middle half of our data is.
And now I can draw
these two arrows, these.
So that's the box part.
And then these two
arrows are what
you would call the whiskers.
And that shows where
all the other data is.
So it's really showing
the spread of the data.
And then the last thing we need
to show is the actual median.
And the median-- I'll do it in
purple-- we already figured out
is 6.
So the median sits right
about-- see, this is 5.
This would 7.5.
6 would be right over there.
So with this one
diagram, you've actually
depicted all of this
information in terms
of where is the median.
The median is at 6.
That is 6 right over there.
Where is the middle
half of the data?
Well, it's between 2.5 and
12.5, between 2.5 and 12.5.
And all of the data, the entire
spread for all of the customers
sits between-- and this is
what the whiskers do for us.
It sits between 1 and
it sits between 22.
And if you wanted to color
code it a little bit better--
let me do that just
because it's fun.
So this data right
over here-- and really,
if you think about it, it's
including this data too.
That's what this
whisker is depicting.
This data right over-- Let me
do that in a different color.
This data right
over here is kind
of the first half of the box.
That data right over here.
Then you have your
median in magenta.
Then this data right over here
is the second part of the box.
So it's all of this
stuff right over here.
And then finally, let
me pick a new color
that I haven't used yet.
This data is kind of
represented by this part,
by this whisker right over here.
Now there's one thing
I want to leave you
with is that I used a method for
this box and whisker diagram.
I found the median.
I use a method where the two
halves, I got rid of the median
and I found the
median of this part,
median of that part.
And that's the
more typical method
for box and whisker plots.
Sometimes when you find
the median of the lower
half and the upper
half, some people
will include this median in both
sets when they calculate it.
But I just want to let
you know that's out there.
But the way that I
did it is actually
the more mainstream way.
That's the way most
calculators, I believe,
actually will do a
box and whisker plot.